I'm Alona Fyshe. I'm a professor at the
University of Alberta and I'm also a
fellow of the Alberta Machine
Intelligence Institute and I'm gonna
follow in Jessica's footsteps in that
I'm not going to talk about exploration
of the outwards, but rather exploration
of inwards and how we know
what we know and how we could tell if a computer knew something too.
so you've probably interacted with a Siri, or somebody like Siri,
either on your phone or maybe you
have an Amazon Alexa in your house.
I have had the experience of saying "hey Siri, call my mom."
And she does actually
place a call to my mother.
But do you think that Siri understands the concept of mother?
Do you think she understands the concept of call?
Even though she's a phone, I think she doesn't understand what even call means.
So I'm interested in asking how do computers
understand meaning and language, and how
could we tell if they understood what we said?
So how do we test understanding?
If I was trying to test whether a person
understood what I was saying I would ask
them to do something and if they did the
right thing then I could say "oh they
understand me." But we've already decided
that that's not how we want to test Siri
Siri does what we asked her to do but we
still don't believe that she understands
us. So let's think about how we test
students we test students every day and
we do things
ask them about things in their world
things that we've taught them to see if
they know what what they've learned. So one thing that we can do to test
students about what what words mean is
to do analogy tests.
So, hammer is to nail as screwdriver is to...
Screw. Very good! Excellent work.
Hammer is to nail as screwdriver is to screw.
You're right. So this
tells us that you understand the
individual words and also the
relationships between the words and so
do you think we could get a computer to
do this task? That's the first
thing I'm going to talk about today.
We're going to use, in order to solve
analogies, we're going to use computer
models of word meaning.
Computer models of word meaning are built on the
fact that words that are similar are
used in similar ways. So if we were to
look through all of the websites on the
internet and look for the word "car" and
the word "truck," they would probably also
both be used in similar contexts. They would both be used
with the words "gas," "drive," "door," "steer,"
etcetera.
That would tell us that they have similar meaning
What computer models of word meaning do is
to use that, leverage that fact in order
to build models. We're going to
calculate statistics about the word
co-occurrence, when two words occur together,
and we're going to turn those
statistics into lists of numbers.
When words have similar meaning, they will
have similar lists.
Here I'm representing the numbers with the color
blue and if it's more blue than it's a
larger number and so these two words, "car"
and "truck," I've made a short list here
and because car and truck are similar
they have similar lists of numbers, but
they're not exactly the same. So we can
use this idea of lists of numbers in
order to tell if two words are similar.
So hammer is to nail as screwdriver is to
screw. now we need to use these lists of
numbers to actually perform the analogy
test. So we're actually going to do is
literally do math on these lists of
numbers so we're gonna take the list
for nail, and subtract the list for
hammer. And add the list for screwdriver,
just element by element, and that gives
us a new vector, sorry a new list of numbers, and that new list of
numbers tends to be close to the correct
answer to the analogy task. So this
hypothetical list of numbers is close to
the co-occurent statistics we see for the
word "screw." So let's test our computer
model.
We're going to do the analogy test
where we choose from five options. So
if we were a randomly guessing, if you
didn't know what you were doing, you
would get 20% on this particular test.
The average US college applicant gets
57%, so better than guessing.
It turns out that these word lists that I
just told you about actually do almost
as well as the US college applicants.
56%.
So, do computers understand language?
Are you convinced? I think it would be right
for you to still be skeptical. I am also
still skeptical. I think we both can
agree that computers do not understand
the meaning of words even though we've
performed these analogy tests as well as
US high school students.
Let's go right to the source. Half of
my work is also on brain imaging and
studying what language looks like in the brain.
So let's see what word meaning looks
like in the brain. The way we're gonna
do this,
remember our computer models are just
lists of numbers.
It turns out that brain
images are also just lists of numbers so
for a particular area the list of
numbers represents how much activity
there is in that area. So in both cases,
we just have lists of numbers and we can
tell how similar the list of numbers are
and we can use that in order to compare
the two sources of information.
Essentially what we're gonna do is take
pairs of concepts, so things like "dog" and
"cat," "car" and "truck" and we're gonna
compare how similar they are in using
the list of numbers from brains and
using the list of numbers from computer models.
We would like to rank
these lists of pairs, and check if the
ranking is similar across their two data
sources. And if it's similar. then we
would say that computers understand
things in the same way that the brain does.
So this is your brain. On the top is
the left side of your brain, and the
bottom is right and I'm highlighting
here just the areas of the brain that
are known to be involved in language
processing. So I just want you to
remember that there's a there's a few
little spots here, and most of them are
on the left-hand side.
So now on the next slide I'm going to
show you essentially the results from
comparing a computer model of meaning to
a human brain. Here we're going to
be colouring the brain with these colours
that represent how correlated those
rankings are. So if it's red or yellow
it's very correlated and if it's more of
a blue than it's less correlated.
If it's grey then it's not significant,
there's no significant relationship
between the computer model and the brain.
The first thing to notice is that
there's nothing that's grey. Which is
remarkable and interesting and not
something that was known before this
research was started. We thought language
was really relegated to these one pieces
but it turns out that language meaning
is all over your brain, you understand
language with your entire brain.
We also see the same pattern of some more red
and yellow on the left hand side but we
see language meaning all over the brain.
And this shows up in other studies too
so this is brain images captured while
people listen to podcasts. and so here we
Here we see if anything is black that mean
it's also not significantly related to
the computer model of meaning, but here
we see lots of parts of the brain are
not black. And that shows us that this
computer model of meaning is related to
how your brain registers meaning as
you're listening to a podcast.
So parts of our brains do represent meaning in
the same way that computers do.
Computers think like us.
Are you convinced?
Again I think you're right
to remain skeptical. But it's interesting
to think about what it would take to
convince you that a computer understood
language.
Thank you very much